it's summer in Taipei and temperatures
have reached a good 30 degrees humidity
is at 70% inside the air conditioners
are running at full blast colonel Wong
is the head of building automation at
Siemens in Taiwan the building has just
had air conditioning installed and it's
Wong's job to make sure that it runs as
efficiently as possible after all German
business has high standards
sensors have been installed to keep the
temperature stable while using as little
energy as possible but the control room
monitor is reporting a problem actually
the third is floors the temperatures the
things is too low and I think the
setpoint should be was justified because
the low temperature means we provide two
cooling energies in the area and that's
what's energy so that's why we we have
we will check the setpoint in regularly
to maintain the energy efficiency for
this building it would take an
engineering team a whole day to readjust
the system but Siemens has no choice if
they want to stay ahead of the cheaper
competition in Asia so far Gauri
encourages their colleagues using the
Desolator
during the day times they are turning on
the ceiling light but during the nine
times that feel nice well turn off asks
the employee if he's using the desk lamp
as well the building owner is a legend
in Taiwan Tong Zhong Chau owns the
biggest real estate empire on the whole
island and is just waiting for his
investment to pay off we're saving on
energy costs and reducing our co2
emissions and water usage we've taken on
our social responsibility and we want to
provide a model for climate protection
in Taiwan our employees would feel happy
at work and the tenants in our apartment
blocks should also profit from these
improvements his headquarters are LEED
certified gold lead is the International
rating system for sustainable buildings
the gold rating was quite an honor the
highest level a platinum rating was
awarded to this tower
Seamans delivers the concept while
others profit from the technology now we
are heading to happy 101 this building
and we are facing a lot of challenges to
the operations because physical power
so they show you how it works around
11,000 people work in this skyscraper
the third highest in the world
ice is produced in the heart of the
building to keep its inhabitants cool
this all happens at night when less
energy is being used during the day two
dozen of these giant refrigerators lend
their cooling powers to the building I
think the major benefit is corporate
image that we can also tell the world
that we are now the worst tallest green
building and I think there's actual
money saving from energy saving that's
really benefit beneficial they save five
hundred forty thousand euros per year to
be exact the Taipei 101 project is a
gateway for the head of Siemens Taiwan
he expects it to lead to further
regional commissions so far the building
automation only contributes to 10% of
the profit of course we have to earn
money and there are different
developments energy prices is one aspect
the the legal framework is another one
which creates a kind of pull in this
market so more and more buildings needs
to be built energy efficient so there is
where we are coming in with our
expertise in building technologies and
energy efficiency mr. Wong has travelled
to the top of the skyscraper to
contemplate his vision here's the happy
city our city a lot of buildings in
there and we hope my companies came from
all more building automation systems and
the solutions for those building just
like we've done for having 101 100%
identification with companies is common
practice in Taiwan and Wong is prepared
to take building automation as far as he
can
you